hello everyone another year has passed
and I'm here simply to wish all of you a
very happy New Year I hope the coming
year is is Meaningful and and brings you
a lot of of joy and development whether
that be in your personal or spiritual or
social life or whatever I hope it's a
meaningful year that will be beneficial
to you and your loved ones
this past year just like last time has
been
pretty crazy here on the channel I've
just watched the the last New Year's
video I did not in that one I said that
at that point so on New Year's Eve last
year we were at almost 300 000
subscribers
and now just a year later we're at
basically I think around
460. so that's
again I I I I don't really know what to
say I would just like to say thank you
to everyone who subscribes who is
engaging with the videos they want
commenting liking I'm just so very
thankful for the community that we have
here
um where there is an open space for
talking about a topic that a lot of
people
maybe don't feel that safe or
comfortable talking about in other
spaces and other places so to say
so I just think that's an amazing thing
just like I said last year and so this
is just a way of of me just saying thank
you to everyone who has made this year
an incredibly
beautiful year for me in many different
ways
um
once again thank you to everyone for
watching and liking and subscribing
um an incredibly big thank you to all of
my patrons whose monetary support really
keep this channel going it is thanks to
all of you that I can
Bible books for research then I'm able
to actually have this basically as a job
you know studying and also conveying and
sharing this love of knowledge and and
and and
learning with you and the audience it's
really an honor for me to be able to do
this basically as as my job so I'm just
so incredibly grateful and honored for
that thank you all so much
uh and of course thank you to all of the
people that I've worked with over the
year and of the years everyone from Xavi
from Seekers of unity and Justin Sledge
and Angela pruca and Andrew Henry
um than a trell
John ravaki everyone who has been part
of this channel over the last year
through collaborations or whatever the
case uh thank you all so much it's been
amazing working with all of you
um I am so impressed and inspired by the
work that you're doing and so to be able
to work together with you guys is always
an honor and a pleasure and I hope to
see us work together more in the future
which I know we will of course it really
we've created a beautiful little
Community here on on YouTube and
elsewhere of
Educators with a passion for for
spreading
trustworthy and reliable information
about topics that are quite difficult
and that don't always
aren't always available in such a way
otherwise when it comes to these topics
so I I think
personally feel like what we're doing is
very meaningful and to be doing it along
with you guys is is incredible
so thank you so much this year we've
we've done a lot of
fun things this year we've talked about
Sikhism we've talked about
um we've done a series on Shi Islam we
have talked more about Sufism of course
we've also started exploring
religion in ancient Greece
we've done some stuff just recently now
we did a big collaboration we're still
in the middle of that collaboration on
neoplatonism which has been really
exciting and I really feel like
personally I feel like some of my best
work has been put out this year my video
on Sufi music was a big passion project
of mine I think that turned out really
well the neoplatonism episode I'm very
happy with as well we did one on music
and Jewish mysticism which was a lot of
fun so yeah I'm very happy with with the
past year so in the last video from from
last New Year's I also had a few sort of
prediction not predictions but I had a
few things that I wanted to do for 2022.
one of them was that we were starting
the let's talk religion podcast which we
have and that's been going great to my
my lovely wife has been doing the the
audio and most of the work with that and
she's done an amazing job I'm very
thankful for that and at this point
we've almost caught up with the videos
so it took both took us basically
exactly a year to for the podcast to
catch up in terms of the episodes so I
think in just a two weeks or so the
podcast will have caught up with the
YouTube channel and from then on we're
gonna start basically posting those
episodes simultaneously as videos and
and podcast episodes so for those of you
who haven't checked out the let's talk
religion podcast I uh highly recommend
you do so if you want to listen to these
episodes while you're on the go or
whatever if you some people prefer to
have to have this kind of content in
audio form and so that is available it
should be available wherever you get
your podcast where that is on Spotify or
or apple or or whatever it is it should
be available there it's called just like
this channel let's talk religion
another goal I had last year was to make
more content on my other channel Philly
Palm which is dedicated primarily to
music and I have also I think
accomplished that I've in general I
wanted to do more music this year and I
it's last year at this point because
it's January 1st when I'm recording this
but anyway
um I've put out some some new music I
put out three new songs with my project
zini I put out a full album of music
from these so the music I make as
background music for these videos I put
out a full album of that stuff called
climbing last summer which a lot of you
guys seem to really enjoy which I'm very
happy with
and on the other channel I've been doing
well I've been posting music I've been
posting uh videos about music history
talking about both my own music but also
famous musicians and composers in
history so that channel has been fairly
active this year which also was one of
my big goals last year I feel like I
kind of achieved so I'm very happy with
that too 2022 is also very special for
me because I sort of finished my run as
a teacher at the school where I was
working which was the most beautiful
thing that I've ever done basically and
and so that was definitely one of the
highlights of the year and for the whole
time when I was teaching they were
always bugged me that I should shout
them out in a video I always said no but
here finally I guess
it's a shout out to my to my students my
wonderful wonderful students I hope I
hope and I know that you're all doing
amazing so so thank you also to you guys
for for the last year and for the
proceeding two years which was a
wonderful experience so thank you all so
much for making this year what it has
been
2022 has been uh great for me I hope it
has been for you as well whether or not
it was I hope again that next year 2023
is going to be meaningful in some way to
you that's I think the the most we can
ask for and probably the best we can ask
for so thank you all so much and I'll
see you in in a very exciting 2023 with
new videos more new plate Newton coming
up we're doing some Norse religion we're
doing some documentaries I'm actually
traveling tomorrow I'm not going to tell
you where but I'm going on a little trip
and I'll hopefully be able to get some
some material to make content for you
from there as well so
I'm very excited hope you are as well
thank you so much and I will see you in
the next video
[Music]